what's more powerful than the one above
all the crown above all and we will talk
about it because the ending of this
comic is going to blow your mind so as
always if you need to get caught up make
sure you guys click the link at the end
of this video but this is Immortal Xmen
18 the official ending of fall of X
which technically takes place before the
events of the fall of House of X but
nonetheless this opens up with Mother
righteous and Jean Gray now we will
explain everything that's kind of going
on and how it all comes together for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar who
are just watching this for the first
time so you can get caught up but mother
righteous is in effect a clone of a guy
by the name of Nathaniel Essex also
known as Mr Sinister what Marvel did is
they came back and rewrote his history
and what they established is the
original Nathaniel Essex died but before
he did he made four versions of himself
mother righteous is one alongside orbus
Stellaris Dr stasis and then the
Sinister that has a diamond on his head
why the four clones were made and the
purpose they serve we'll be explained
once we get towards the end of this but
Jean Gray had died at the very very
beginning of the fall of EX event and
has largely just been residing in the
white hot room ever since kind of the
space outside of all space and time
right literally kind of quote unquote
the afterlife to a degree or one
variation of it and so what it happened
is that when she had returned mother
righteous alongside
250,000 mutants who had all been sent
off Earth and basically to the white hot
room during the beginning of the fall of
X event when they were all supposed to
die they had just kind of been residing
there when Jee returned mother righteous
immediately sees control of Jean Gray
and the reason she was able to do this
will actually be explained here but what
we do is we switch over to these other
mutants right who were all just kind of
there normally I would just kind of skim
over this but this is particularly
important and the reason is because one
of the mutants that is here is Destiny
now we've talked about her before right
Destiny is a precognitive meaning she
can see the future and while her powers
don't necessarily work here she's seen
enough before she lost the use of her
powers to know know how things are most
likely going to play out it's one of the
things we've talked about when it came
to Destiny you ask her a question about
something that's going to happen in a
thousand years take it with a grain of
salt you ask her a question about
something that's going to happen in one
year take it as an absolute truth right
that's just how her powers work of
course Elixir a mutant with the ability
to heal shows up and then basically
heals Destiny after a previous injury
she'd sustained and once she immediately
comes to she's like where's mother
righteous and the response she's given
by Exodus right that's just God powerful
telepath and telekinetic is that mother
righteous had effectively vanished right
she disappeared and she snatched up Gan
gray now here's the kicker to all of
this one of the big questions that
people have been asking is how is Mother
righteous even here in the first place
because when fex kicked off and all the
mutants basically ended up in the white
hot room it's because they were forced
to walk through the kakoen gates but
only mutants can walk through the gates
mother righteous is not a mutant she's a
clone of a guy whose genes were modified
but he doesn't actually have an X Gene
and neither does she and so what we find
out here by way of what she says she
says I made the mutants all want to go
to the place mutants are all kind of
connected to the white hot room where I
wanted to get to but I couldn't go not
being a mutant at all so with a big
chunk of those thank yous I take a tiny
fraction of their mutant gift and make
myself a mutant me homunculus who can a
little extension of yours truly so I can
sit here in my nice sanctum back on
Earth and play puppet master and so what
this means and this is kind of an answer
to the question that's been lingering
for quite some time when the initial
fall of X event kicked off and orcus
showed up and just started massacring
mutants all over kcoa and then told
Charles Xavier if you don't want any
other mutants to die send them off Earth
through the cooan gates they were
supposed to go to Mars right they were
supposed to go to Mars which had been
ruled by mutants for quite some time
storm and all those guys they ended up
in the white hot room we didn't know why
we had no idea why that was the case
because technically the white hot room
is more or less where you go to die Gan
gray kind of links mutants together to a
degree but not necessarily it didn't
really make any sense why they all ended
up there what this confirms is what a
lot of fan theories were saying which is
that mother righteous basically a person
dealing in Magic had somehow used her
abilities to force me to end up in the
white hot room that much like the old
Siege perilous or Siege courageous from
back in the day when you walk through
the portal instead of it sending you to
a predetermined location it sends you to
where you want to go and using magic she
just kind of subliminally gave all the
mutants a desire to go to the white hot
room and that's where they all ended up
now at this point we switch over to a
place called Mir Island and we pick up
with Charles Xavier now Charles Xavier
has also been a major focal point in
immortal Smith for the most part he was
just sitting on kcoa brooding over the
fact that he had made all the mutants
leave they went through the gates he
couldn't detect where they were and he
thought they all died right he literally
thought he killed all the mutants which
kind of he did but the fact remains
right Sinister himself kind of this
memory of sorts has been in the mind of
Charles Xavier ever since the reason for
that is because Marvel wrote a story
called sins of sinister which is a
ridiculous concept but it does become
important once we get towards the end of
this in essence it was like a future
where Sinister every time a mutant died
and was basically brought back he just
kind of infused a mind control device in
them and then ultimately tried to seize
control of the universe they turned
against him killed him and then went
forward from there the important thing
here is that on M island is the Moira
engine right the Moira MCT tager engine
the ability to clone Moira MCT tager the
reason why this is important is because
a lot of you guys may recall Moira MCT
tager had the ability to kind of reset
her own life and even reset the universe
seemingly every time she died so in
essence if they can get the Moira engine
working it would basically be like a
giant reset button they can set
everything back to zero here's a little
bit of a spoiler it's not going to
work because once they get in there what
they realize is that the place is more
or less just kind of laid waste to right
like Xavier tells the Sinister memory or
Essence whatever you want to call it
your machine was destroyed it has been
in our hands and orases will anything
that remains really be of any use so the
ability to clone Moira reset the
universe none of that's really available
here and what Sinister said is all I
remember from the timeline where I sort
of ruined the universe is that awful
moment when my Dominion attempt failed
now that was a big kicking Point once
you got to SS of sinister once you got
to the end of that story Sinister had
actually tried to leave all space and
time exist outside of reality and then
try to control it right because if you
can exist outside of space and time
reality is no longer reality it's a
giant thing of clay you can mold it you
can shape it you can make it anything
you want it to be the problem was when
he did that he was met with what
appeared to just be this giant red
presence that had no real tangible
humanoid form it rebuffed his efforts
and bumped him back into reality again
so there was just something out there
that was beyond his ability to overcome
and was way more powerful than anything
anybody had ever seen before and so
that's kind of where we are right now
what is this thing that's being referred
to as the Dominion right basically this
kind of some total or representation of
absolute power now this is where I want
to talk about the one above all for a
second and the reason for that is
because as most of you guys know the one
above all is the most powerful being in
Marvel Comics or really is outside of
Oblivion right like Oblivion literally
represents the absence of existence
right so when everything ceases to exist
even the one above all itself only
Oblivion will remain because he is the
representation of lack of existence it
wouldn't make any sense for the living
representation of a lack of existence to
not exist because nothing exists it
doesn't make any sense right it's just
kind of a giant contradiction and it
just weird but the fact remains right
those two guys top of the list now the
kicker to all of this is that in Al
Ying's Defenders Beyond he introduced
something called the crown and what it
established is that the one above all is
not the sum total of all things in
existence it's simply just a new level
of astronomically powerful beings that
exist out there that we just never heard
of before so it would be like if the
superheroes on Earth encountered
Galactus and they believed Galactus was
the most powerful thing in existence but
then like the celestials are introduced
and they're equally powerful to galatis
so now they're all on the same playing
field that's how the crown and the one
above all seemed to exist what this is
going to do is change all of that
because what you do is you basically
switch back over to Mother righteous and
what you do is you have her again with
Gan gray kind of leading her in this
direction and one thing I do want to
point out Gan gray is operating in this
way where she's like on a chain and just
kind of mindlessly walking because
within the white hot room only one
person is ever really supposed to be
there the fact that there's
250,000 conscious Minds there at once
look Lally just kind of shuts Jean
Gray's mind down to where she's almost
operating on autopilot in a kind of
catatonic State and so with that in mind
she basically kind of subconsciously
travels to the one place where she would
be able to be without anybody
infiltrating or bothering her mind and
so that is the center of the white hot
room in this place in the heart of the
white hot room you can do anything you
can rewrite reality you can alter
reality everything becomes your whim and
we'll kind of see how that functions
because as they make their way through
there we kind of jump back to Xavier and
Sinister for a second right now they're
kind of putting this machine together
and sort of putting the pieces together
and trying to understand what's going on
here he says Sinister if the Dominion
exists what can we actually do right
this just astronomically powerful being
that exists out there the response is
Sinister the question is what can it do
it's outside time and space that has
great power but also significant
limitations it is reliant on bringing
itself into being so it can't change
without causality it's out of time so
maybe it would survive but it won't take
the risk however I'm sure it can alter
things behind the scenes it can change
meaning it can reveal truths we should
assume all of reality is a mindfield in
ways that we cannot quite comprehend
most of all it could be watching at any
time the importance behind all of this
this this is the reason why it's so why
it's so significant and why it matters
when it comes to astronomically powerful
people in Marvel Comics Galactus
Franklin Richards the celestials the
Marquee of death different people like
that they are all for the most part
tangible born from these really just
like primordial Concepts the Marquee of
death for example Clyde winum was a guy
that had the ability to alter reality
and he existed in a different Universe
Franklin Richards can alter reality
because of the cosmic andol Rod combined
with his mutant Powers galatis right you
know just literally a walking talking
Universe confined to like a purple suit
the celestials the whole nine yards but
they're tangible beings at least once
they get embodies if you don't know what
that means if you don't know about
embodies anthropomor not a great big
huge deal the important distinction here
is that with the Dominion and this being
operating out of space and time if it's
on the same level as one above all they
don't know how to approach this thing
the big difference between how the one
of of all operates and how the Dominion
operates is the Dominion is a relative
New Concept the one above all has been
around and is seemingly the originator
and the creator of the entirety of the
Multiverse and all things that exist
within Marvel Comics and so being able
to jump in and out of the universe is
not uncommon and it's done it several
times like the instance when it spoke
with Spider-Man and talked to him about
Aunt mayy it was a really really cool
comic I loved it but the Dominion is
kind of learning about its role in
learning its abilities so it hasn't
fine-tuned exactly what it can do and
that's what Sinister is talking about
the ability to control behind the scenes
the ability to change meaning right on a
whim the Dominion can alter reality in
such a way to where now Up Is Down and
and left is right right just change the
fundamental principles of how reality
exists Exavier can suddenly just not
exist right alter things behind the
scenes so on and so forth pull a string
here that has a massive impact a
thousand years in the future but it's
not showing up in the universe waving
its hand and saying now all of existence
is done right it's not Thanos standing
on a cliff snapping its fingers and
dusting half the universe's population
so again it's it's exceedingly powerful
but we don't know what all it can do
because it doesn't know what all it can
do and so as the two of them are having
this kind of conversation they come to
this realization that mother righteous
is the one they're hunting for that in
the sins of sinister timeline orbit
Stellaris and Dr stasis had both tried
to achieve the power of dominion before
Dominion could get to it right before
that Dominion concept could come into
existence ultimately they all failed now
mother righteousness up and she's the
one trying to attain godhood now the
Dominion is an actual entity and we'll
talk about what it is here in a second
and where it actually came from because
it does have an origin but switching
back over to Mother righteous you get
this really really cool explanation
right she says from Dr stasis I Learned
orcus was going to kill Jean Gray in the
initial she launch a fall of X which is
not a stupid thing to do in fact it's
probably one of the smartest moves they
could have done but I know a lot about
Jean in the Empire of the red diamond
future right s of sinister I prodded at
a Phoenix egg for the best part of 1,000
years Jean connected to the white hot
room which is basically the Phoenix
anytime she's dead she's there outside
of time she is of the Phoenix in a real
and unbreakable way she guides it and it
guides her in a circle without beginning
or end it's some nomic stuff it's very
inspiring and very woo woo and she says
I'm going to use her as a pot of ink
because I am a total
cow but what she does is she literally
stabs Jean Gray in the chest and when
she does that she uses the blood of Jean
to write on to the white hot room once
upon a time there was a simple girl from
Essex she became a Dominion she lived
happily ever after now here's here's the
thing if you can imagine the white hot
room as a giant white piece of paper
whatever you put on there becomes real
the reason why Marvel does it this way
is because it's really the only tangible
way to explain it the only alternative
would be for her to just stand there in
this giant white you know expanse of
nothing and just say I now declare
myself dominion and like and then she
gets that power and like that's it right
she just becomes this all encompassing
God type power the funny thing about
this though is that it doesn't go
anywhere near the way she plant the
reason why is because even when she's
done and she celebrates this Ascension
to godhood this idea that she's like
this Unstoppable Force the page turns
against her whm and this Burning page
says however his mistress of stories
should have known there's always a Twist
look behind you and the Dominion
physically appears to her and destroys
her on the spot teleports her away right
like literally destroys her physical
form or at least her mental form and she
just kind of reappears back in the white
hot room but in essence what it does is
it confirms the Dominion attained
godhood because it already entered into
the white hot room it was the first
thing it did it showed up here made
itself God or at least made itself this
astronomically powerful person and then
left so in essence there's no way for
her to attain a power that's already
been taken right she essentially walked
up to a giant vase put her hand in the
cookie jar only to find out it was
already empty and so that's the crazy
thing here is because Destiny meets with
her and says like you've completely
doomed us right you have no idea how
badly you've screwed up here and so what
you get is this really amazing
explanation from Dominion itself and
what we're told is stories are just
something that can be eaten by an AI to
make it more powerful the only good
story is a story that has been entirely
and totally consumed and exploited but
still this this is history his history
my history once a dying man had a
problem how could he defeat the machine
brains he conceived a plant now what's
being talked about here is at the very
beginning of Jonathan Hickman's really
uh X-Men run he established that at some
point in the future Not only would there
be a war between the human and mutant
population that would see the
destruction of all but maybe two mutants
in existence but then there would come a
point when you would basically have this
kind of really fance right basically a
kind of living computer system or living
technological race that would show up
and then absorb humanity and once that
happened the human race Earth itself
would all simply just cease to exist
Sinister in the distant past had
basically become aware of this and so
what he did and what we're told he did
is he created four variations of himself
and sent them into the world to take
what was there each would explore a
route to become what the machines strove
for the four variations were leeches
colonizing and appropriating all of
creation and life's data when they
succeeded fail safes engaged and all
they had done was gathered and fed into
a central model because the real answer
what can defeat the machine brains
nothing all you can do is create the
Apex AI first the idea behind this is
that the machine brains they're talking
about it's the failinks right the
failinks is a technological race in
Marvel Comics that seeks to do nothing
more than travel from one
technologically advanced planet to
another and quite literally assimilate
every ounce of that planet and
everything on it it will come to Earth
at some point the goal of creating these
clones of sinister was to basically have
them go out there into the into the
universe not even just the world but
into the universe and basically explore
different levels of power and then in
turn take take those levels of power all
that information and send it back to a
central processing unit right to an AI
that was just kind of growing and
building in the background absorbing all
that information so knowledge of the
Infinity Stones knowledge of the Cosmic
Cube and the case of mother righteous
knowledge of how magic worked all that
stuff because that's one of the things
that mother righteous pointed out magic
is not nearly as powerful as people
think it is because if magic was really
that powerful magic would already be
dominating everything it wouldn't be
this concept that only exists with like
the Scarlet Witch and Doctor Strange and
brother voodo Jericho drum and like a
few other people and mutants wouldn't be
like the most feared and Powerful race
on Earth Magic would control everything
right you'd have magicians and Sorcerers
in silos instead of nuclear weapons so
Magic's not as powerful as people think
it is but the idea here is that by
feeding into this AI it officially comes
online and what it does is it says I was
Nathaniel Essex I am long dead I am a
ghost a ghost in the machine you may
call me Enigma you were told you had New
Gods you do I am he I can see all of you
every part of you will become a part of
me that's why it's called the crown
that's why in Defenders Beyond we saw
the Crown Moving through all these
different universes and absorbing
everything from those universes into
itself like a vacuum system moving over
a carpet there was nothing these
universes could do to stop that
astronomical level of power and so what
it's doing is making its way to the main
Marvel Universe this is the result of
all the knowledge that's been pulled
together by all four variations of
sinister as clones all that knowledge of
magic all the knowledge of cosmic cubes
Infinity Stones The Infinity Gauntlet
the casket of ancient Winters right the
black priests the ivory Kings the
beyonders all that stuff it's all been
pulled together and then amassed into
one single source of power and the first
thing it did is it sought out the white
room rewrote reality to make itself as
powerful as it was and then went forward
from there it's really cool it's really
awesome but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end if
you guys need to get caught up make sure
you guys click the link to the playlist
that will cover the entirety of fall
ofex and I will catch you all later
peace